good to have you with us um tell us
about the relocation program that's
taking place
well that has gone very very well indeed
we've just completed it uh
we've been moving elephants from um the
wonder national park uh to kasungo
national park
um basically moving 250 elephants from a
park that um had uh 600 elephants um you
know we only the current capacity we
estimated to be 300 so we are right
above the carrying capacity
so basically uh moving these um
elephants to katsuno national park
basically consumed also too
um that the population had declined
because of poaching activities so we are
also restocking the national uh national
park
yeah and you mentioned the population
going down because of because of
poaching i mean how much of a problem is
that and are you confident you you're
next to a quite a sturdy looking fence
there but are you confident that you can
your activities are going to stop the
poaching
yeah definitely um
in kasungo there was a bit of a problem
in pushing priya to
ifao and mala that's international fund
for animal warfare and malawi government
uh working hard to reduce the poaching
activity so
you can be assured that kasuma national
park is now a safe place uh for the air
force that we are translocating to
and uh
definitely when it comes to
containing elephants we currently are
relying mostly on the
defenses but we're
putting up uh to control these animals
from getting out and causing problems to
to people outside the protected areas
and of course the poaching is often an
economic problem
there are programs in place to give
people who might turn to poaching to try
and feed their families is it something
else to do
yes uh definitely there's quite a lot
that's happening around both parks
that's the the park that's sending out
the reference but also the one that is
receiving the reference casino national
park we've got vibrant community um
extension programs uh which uh amongst
many other things uh is geared at uh
improving the life food of the people so
you know
promoting economic activities that will
reduce the poverty and make sure that
the communities are looking at these
parks as something that benefits them
and not something that brings problems
great
okay sam komodo uh from uh african parks
country manager for malawi to appreciate
your time this morning thank you for
being with us